okay before we get to the questions from
the people who wrote in would you like
to respond Steve to that editorial about
Ayn Rand and look I mean when I first
met you you you the first thing you told
me is I'm a libertarian that's what I
know I'm so disappointed you left the
flock but what about FEMA I didn't make
that up Ron Paul doesn't believe in FEMA
look I don't agree with everything that
Ron Paul believes him but I do think I'm
something you're way to me you're a
libertarian who doesn't believe in all
the [ __ ] that these I don't believe
in everything do you believe in
everything that liberals say or do you
believe in everything the Socialists say
no no so but don't just criticize the
whole movie is actually libertarian that
mindset no I do believe maybe no you're
a kind of a socialist so you wouldn't be
in that mindset right America socially
the two most popular programs in America
are Social Security and Medicare and
that social yes but Bill my point so
America so this is the point of my but
why is America the wealthiest country in
the history of the world because we are
a system that was beta based on the free
enterprise system maryville first of all
for the middle class and working class
of this country America is not the
wealthiest country in the history of the
world
right around America today and this is
an important point that we don't talk
about enough bill in America today we
have the most unequal distribution of
wealth and income of any major country
on earth you're at the top one percent
only thirty eight percent of the wealth
the bottom sixty percent own 2.3 percent
of the wealth that is immoral that's
wrong and that it's bad economics okay
let us move on to the questions of
people have wrote in Stuart our ask you
Zach what do you think will happen with
the North Carolina effort to subvert the
First Amendment by introducing a bill oh
yes I wrote about to declare an official
state religion and oddly I understand
that religion is Islam
that is worth Carol it's like it's like
the the pre-civil warrior yeah and so
luckily that seems to have been table
luckily but it says something that all
these bills keep getting introduced like
the creationism the just the first
moment doesn't apply to us we're gonna I
mean there's a bill movie Xena had to
basically put the Lord's Prayer in the
schools now it's just all these bills
keep happening it's against the
separation of church and state
unconstitutional it's so ironic that
these are it's probably the future with
the tea bags hanging off their head
because there's such strict
constitutional yes that's true if they
want a state religion it's asking for a
huge court case no we still have
segregated proms yes well I saw that too
recently interestingly I better know yes
okay
what is the one surprising political
lesson you've learned by taking a stand
against teaching creationism there's
always you can always say and do the
right thing and there's always a right
answer that we shouldn't be teaching
creationism I can be brave and snap and
say that when you're just scared
and we need a few million more young
people like this young no yes
let me just add we're not going to get
them why does America take the
possibility of a nuclear Iran so
seriously while in comparison seeming to
take the reality of a nuclear North
Korea not so seriously hmm hmm you have
any thoughts on that you looking at me
yeah looking at you I think partly
because Iran is in the middle of a very
very volatile part of the world North
Korea is kind of off in its own corner
and can I also mention that North Korea
is a stunted state is probably the
saddest sickest state in the world and
Iran is not the Ran's that could do
something really staying afloat because
of China where we talk about North Korea
we're really talking about our
relationship with China that's Korean
North Korea's very much acting like an
irrational child but they they play this
game of manipulation and I actually I
actually commend the White House for
where they've handled it because they
have not been willing to play their
games they're not giving in the
attention that that they're wanting to
get ultimately I think they're handling
it just neither of these countries
having a nuclear bomb is the greatest
danger to the planet in 50 years I mean
these are these are incredibly unstable
governments with wackos running them
it's a really really scary situation
very refreshing that he Republican give
some credit to the White House for
anything maybe because I mean they so
often work backwards from whatever Obama
just did is the worst thing that ever
happened
I mean now hold on Newt Gingrich was
against the liberals did the exact same
thing when it came to george w bush no
they they did - no Bush did it it might
be wrong no no just the most of what
Bush did was well multiple no it's not
especially and especially in foreign
affairs Newt Gingrich is all about we
have to Bob Libby we have to bomb Libya
the second Obama bombed Libya how dare
we bomb Libya and I think in in terms of
the Bush administration you have a
tragedy go shelf a guy who's actually a
fairly nice guy just happen to be the
worst president in the modern history
are gonna I don't say that way I don't
say that with pride I'm chairman of the
Veterans Committee and I'm here in LA
today visiting some VA facilities we are
looking forget for a moment the 4,500
guys who died when women who died and
the cost of the war we're looking at
tens and tens of thousands of brave good
people coming back from Iraq and
Afghanistan with post-traumatic stress
disorder and traumatic brain injury that
is a war we should never have gotten and
so many of them lost is so horrible if
what I read in the paper lately is true
so many of them can't get the help they
need know that is a giant back no no no
no be careful about what Bill here's the
story we have a serious problem in
processing claims right and we're
working hard on that but in terms of
health care no terms of health care the
VA has a very strong system anybody can
walk in the door and get treaty it was
like a 273 day wait okay what claims for
clinometer health okay they're a person
living on the knife's edge and you need
you're right that 273 days you don't
care what their absolutely correct and
we're working to transform that's your
right but in terms of health care that
should be your first priority frankly
should be a major priority and we are
putting money into it and we are an
total agreement on the panel we're going
away from paper into papers but in terms
of health care veterans should know if
you served in Iraq and Afghanistan five
years of free health care walk in the
door get the VA okay final question for
Sebastian as someone who has made his
living documentary war what is your
stance on the gun control debate oh god
it seems like nobody's happy and we have
to keep talking till we have an
agreement I mean this isn't working for
anybody clearly so well we saw this week
Connecticut passed a law a mr. kiss gun
law in the country will it change
anything
already didn't they already have the
strictest gun roster the country before
I mean but will it change anything I
think it will I mean I mean I don't know
it's the will of the people for it to
change you know this is one area where I
say you know the Democrats are almost as
guilty and and that's because there were
a lot of times it was back to getting
reelected you know this I mean energy
stitch would see we see 91 percent want
stricter background checks but frankly
those that vote in the primaries those
that actually get these people elected
aren't in line with where the rest of
the country is and that's a problem but
yeah I mean the Republicans I don't
agree with what they say about it but
the Democrats it just is in a way it's
harder to listen to because I think it's
such [ __ ] you know the way they
pound their fists if we only had this
law well you know I hear them say
because this has not killed 26 people at
the school in five minutes and if he
didn't have a Bushmaster really you
can't kill 26 people in five minutes if
you had three other guns or and into two
thousand of the guns they don't want to
make it illegal bill c'mon I have some
courage to do it it butts up my courage
to say the second of men are you
antiquated we should just take about
half a page one rewrite on that [ __ ] let
me let me say this I certainly agree
that we've gotta move out on gun control
but maybe the more important issue is we
got millions of folks walking the
streets who are in need of mental health
answer and they can't walk into a place
to get it and that's it that's a risk
this is the NRA talking point well I'm
not saying it's wrong but I'm just
saying that's what they look I can tell
you in my office and I think every
senator will tell you people call up and
they say you know my brother I'm really
worried about him I don't know what he's
gonna do to himself I don't know he's
gonna do to somebody else he needs help
we can't find the help that's all we
can't afford that we can't afford the
help that's going on all over the
country we got to address that issue of
mental health and primary health care in
general
stay safe everybody laugh
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10:00 ask bill and his guests or
questions right after the show at
hbo.com